congressman Matt Gaetz represents the
state of Florida he joins us tonight
congressman thanks all for coming on
it's good to be on Tucker now you have
read this memo assure us that it's not
being oversold do you think this memo
will change the conversation about how
surveillance is used against American
citizens absolutely Tucker and there are
two things that the American people
should evaluate when they read this memo
the first is you've got to evaluate the
memo in the context of the five months
of missing text messages between Peter
struck and its mistress Lisa page you
can't evaluate those two things
separately they have to be evaluated
together second thing the American women
I beg your pardon me just stop you there
what how are those connected exactly
well Tucker again I can't get into
specifics of precisely that connectivity
I can only say that I don't think it's
an accident that struck and Paige who
were volleying text messages back and
forth more than a high school
cheerleading squad all of a sudden have
a five-month black hole in the middle of
that exchange right at the exact time
that one would anticipate a conspiracy
would be ongoing to undermine the
president ending in the appointment of
robert muller conspicuously the very day
that the struck in Paige text messages
come back online so that's no
coincidence the second thing you've got
to evaluate is the manner in which
evidence presented to the court was
corroborated the problem with lies is
that you got to keep telling them you
can't just tell one lie you have to then
use other lies to corroborate your
existing lies it's my position that the
Muller probe is intractably infected
that it is built on a rotten foundation
and that it should end immediately so
that we can focus on the real challenge
of reforming the FBI and the Department
of Justice so that this never happens
again under a Republican or Democrat
administration so and that's right it's
a bipartisan concern because what you're
suggesting is corruption so deep and
menacing that every American ought to be
really upset about it can you pledge as
a member of Congress that you will do
everything you can to expose this and
you know let people make their own
decisions about whether it's appalling
or not but don't you think it's
important for our citizens to have faith
in their government and in order to have
that faith they need more information
soon well absolutely you know I'm not
having been
Congress for a very long time but I
don't think you solve a lot of problems
by having members of Congress meet with
each other behind closed doors and share
their outrage with each other I think
we've got to have sunlight transparency
so that we can all have a national
debate about what type of government we
want to have what type of surveillance
system we want to have what type of
information has to corroborate the stuff
that is presented to courts before
people's Liberty is impaired and so I
think that that's an important national
discussion to have and I think the only
way we're going to get there is by
releasing this memo the good news is
that Devin Nunez and the members of the
Intelligence Committee on the Republican
side want to do that the Democrats are
all over the place I have a hard time
keeping track of where they are so this
they vote against allowing members of
Congress to see it then they now
apparently have their own memo which is
just a ludicrous proposition I mean it
would be interesting we can't
successfully get any Democrat on the
show to explain even do you hear the
argument against releasing it but am I
mistaken
in remembering that the fiesel I was
just reauthorized by Congress I think
that's right wouldn't have been helpful
to have this argument before that
happened I would have preferred that
Tucker it is important to note that the
reauthorization of FISA was not a
blanket reauthorization there were
additional due process protections that
were included that was specifically for
the 702 section of FISA which deals with
overseas collection of intelligence and
when we released the memo we'll be able
to see how that precisely interacts or
or maybe doesn't interact but again
can't confirm or deny those details so
the rest of us are getting really
anxious not because of partisan reasons
but because you want to trust that your
government's law enforcement agencies
aren't being used for political purposes
really simple and important when are we
going to see the memo I think that we'll
see it within the next two weeks the
important thing is that now Democrats
are making a claim that the memo is
conclusive so I think chairman Nunez is
right to look at what supporting
information can be released along with
the memo that validates it I think that
will help us to be able to have a more
robust fact-based discussion rather than
just lobbing conclusions at one another
and that's why the memo hasn't been
released yet I think the Chairman and
the committee are rightfully going
through that process so that we don't
disclose sources and methods or put on
there
Americans who are downrange in any
jeopardy but that we absolutely expose
what I believe is a deep-seated
corruption that has really undermined
this presidency unfortunately now I
think that's I think that's why I see
the Intel community specializes in
releasing their conclusions without
telling you how they got there and it
does not inspire trust congressman thank
you very much for coming on tonight